hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the sequel to the best pocket camera
ever made two years running this is the
sony rx100 mark iv now i've already
reviewed the rx100 mark iii in detail
last year so i'll link that video right
below the like button and if you guys
have already seen it you know i like
that camera a lot so the rx100 mark iv
will be basically a very familiar camera
to people who have used any previous
rx100 right so the mark ii here as you
can see it had a hot shoe on the top
then the mark 3 the next year ditched
that hot shoe for an optical viewfinder
and now we have the mark iv which
feature wise is like an enhanced version
of the mark iii so the new camera is
rocking a stacked one-inch 21 megapixel
sensor as its biggest new feature behind
the same 24 to 70 millimeter glass and
this sensor allows for things that make
this camera a lot faster than previous
generations that's the big difference
autofocus for photos is blindingly crazy
fast you can now take photos with a 32
000 of a second electronic shutter
that's really fast and you can now
record video in full 4k and there's also
now a high frame rate mode that allows
you to record video at up to 960 frames
per second it also has a much improved
electronic viewfinder so if you flip it
out and if you actually use this evf
you'll notice it's right away a lot
sharper than the last one it's actually
kind of trippy when looking at like a
shallow depth of field shot through the
viewfinder kind of looks like a vr
headset and it can actually now be
disconnected from the power setting so
you can close the evf without turning
the camera off if you want and that
famous ring around the zeiss lens on the
front of the camera is improved too it's
a little bit thicker a little bit
smoother and overall better built and it
can still be used to control things like
aperture or zoom or even manual focus if
you wanted to and then you can't forget
the articulating lcd screen the pop-up
flash that can be used to bounce light
off the wall or the ceiling and the nfc
and wi-fi chips inside to let you
instantly transfer full resolution
photos from the sd card to whatever
smartphone you have so all this inside a
metal body that can take a beating it's
built like an absolute tank i mean this
is a seriously well-rounded pocket
camera speaking of sd cards though you
got to mention you have to make sure you
get the right one only certain sd cards
will work with the 4k video other photos
and stuff will still work but you need
specifically a uhs iu3 compatible memory
card to shoot in 4k i'll link the one i
use below to avoid confusion the slow
motion stuff was actually really cool i
think at 240 frames per second you can
pull off some really cool stuff and even
at 480 frames per second you can really
start to slow stuff down a lot and yet
keep a lot of the quality sony says
you're getting 720p video out of it
though i think at this point we all kind
of know that it's not quite 720p video
but it looks pretty good anyway since
it's so slow and then uh 960 frames per
second gets to the point where it really
doesn't look that good anymore i'd
actually stay away from this even though
you can get it super
super slow uh when slowing back down to
30 frames per second it doesn't look
anywhere near 720p and it's very noisy
and grainy so it's kind of a neat trick
up its sleeve that you can record a few
seconds at 960 frames per second but i
wouldn't use it all too much and i'd
stick with the lower frame rates for the
higher quality but the one feature that
i and a lot of other youtubers were
really interested in when this camera
was first announced was its 4k video and
it looks really good i love the 4k video
that comes from the rx100 mark iv it can
be seriously beautiful none of that
upscaled 1080p or over sharpened over
process looking smartphone video this is
a huge step up from that and it looks
really good it has optical image
stabilization color is on point dynamic
range is great and has a big enough
sensor to get some shallow depth of
field going if you can give it a second
to focus this camera can give you like
the best looking videos the best looking
vlogs even in the business i don't know
how many vloggers care about quality
like this but the camera takes some
seriously crispy video case in point my
entire last video about the moto x style
was shot you guessed it on the rx100
mark iv and it was actually kind of the
perfect application for it it was all
indoors where the light wasn't that
great but i shot an s-log so i could
really push the images in grading
without losing much quality and i don't
need much of a zoom range either inside
since my subject is right in front of me
so if you enjoyed the quality of that
video boom right there is your 6 minute
4k low light video sample but
it is definitely not perfect first of
all the autofocus during video is
definitely slow this is actually usually
the typical experience here with
shooting video with the rx100 and also
sort of a bigger complaint of the
previous ones and it remains if you're
shooting with a shallow depth of field
with a lot of subject isolation and a
blurred background the camera can take a
while to focus on objects that aren't
faces also in this shot thanks to
michael fisher of pocket now for being
the model here uh it basically refused
to focus on the subject i wanted it to
it was in auto focus mode if i did go to
manual focus i would have been able to
nail it but it wasn't so i had to scrap
that shot and you're also limited to
five minutes at a time of 4k video
recording but not for processing reasons
or anything it's actually just because
of heat this thing makes a lot of heat
when shooting a lot of 4k video and
actually chews through battery really
quickly during this too this is the
rx100 mark iv after just the first five
minutes of 4k recording and in the
middle of my third consecutive clip of
doing this it just shut down from
overheating and refused to turn on for
about 10 minutes i actually dealt with
this problem at the motorola event
literally standing there in the event
playing with the phone just holding the
overheated camera waiting for it to be
able to turn on again but then again if
it's making super crispy videos like
that i can't even really be mad so at
the end of the day this camera is really
great but not quite perfect i would
still put it as the best hybrid like
pocket video camera in the world for
photos and videos if you're into both
but as far as it being a thousand dollar
video camera it's kind of hard to
consider this like the perfect youtube
camera i know a lot of people have said
like this you know because it shoots 4k
video and it has such a crispy image is
basically like the perfect camera to buy
to start a youtube channel or even run a
youtube channel you don't have to buy a
thousand dollar camera to start but if i
would nitpick i would say that this
isn't the perfect youtube camera because
of the slower autofocus uh because of
the fact that if you want to shoot in 4k
you're limited to 5 minutes and then
it'll start to overheat and if you want
to shoot for long periods of time you're
basically using this as a 1080p camera
which means you might as well get the
mark iii and then the fact that you
can't use any audio inputs and the
microphone that's built in isn't all
that great you know if i'm nitpicking
for a thousand bucks you could probably
go with something like a dslr or i'll
try to link some other options below or
even like i said something like the
rx100 mark iii
but i think this is one generation away
from being something really incredible i
think the rx100 mark v is probably going
to be able to next year shoot 4k video
without overheating without a five
minute limit and might even have audio
input maybe if sony's listening to us so
this is a pretty great camera to start
good job sony i know it's not the first
pocket camera you've ever made but uh
looking forward to the rx100 mark v
already thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one
peace